[Music]
start churning butter and put on your
church shoes little sister because we're
about to a blast-off what is it you're
trying to say we're going the Internet
[Music]
the most beautiful miracle I've ever
seen
welcome to the search bar what can I
help you find today umbrella
Umbridge Oh mommy no no is that no doubt
no it's from Rach ergonomics Urban
Outfitters cool I'm pretty sure he's
just trying to guess what you're gonna
say my auto failures to touch aggressive
today let me try
take me to a website that's super
intense and really nuts oh I don't have
one result characters
come with us
[Music]
hi ladies I'm a princess - what kind of
a princess are you huh do you have magic
hair no magic hands
no do animals talk to you no boy are you
Paul is no cursed no kidnapped or
enslave no are you guys okay police do
people assume all your problems got
solved because a big strong man showed
up well rapes the Internet shouldn't be
Ralph Rex the Internet
yes since he is wreck-it Ralph yeah but
break the Internet it's like a thing
right it's just wrecking it kind of
sounds better doesn't it you're not
wrong
[Music]